when you were talking about your dad and
you and he was dying
why did you and your dad sing this the
neil young song old man to one another
what was that about like was that your
song with him
oh the last thing we did together we
drank whiskey together
um he's a he's a big he was a big
drinker i'm a big drinker
he was in the hospital for his liver you
know drank himself to
you know death yeah essentially
you know he was just like let's let's
have a drink so i snuck
snuck a bottle in the hospital you know
we had we were having this drink
and i was asking questions about
my birth because and i was i was
encouraged to
find things out about myself you know
that i didn't really care
myself to ask about so that's how i
ended up you know on the album i put a
clip on my dad explaining that while i
was
born with the umbilical cord wrapped
around my neck and you know
that like tweezered my head loose and i
had
like heart problems all this weird stuff
with my birth and
you know at some point we got onto music
and i was talking about how
you know i like this one like live neil
young album he did old man like for one
of the one of the first times and
my dad was like oh i love i love i love
that song and i was like you do
like he wasn't much of a rock and roll
guy you know so like
we played the song on my cell phone and
we sang and we were just drinking
whiskey and singing it and
i got in the car two days after
it passed and i remember i was like
screaming at the world just like
because you know they say like the
spirit's supposed to come be with you or
whatever and
i was like where are you at you know
like i'm ready for you to come you know
protect me now and
i got in the car and i was driving and
like neil young came on and
the radio turned itself up i'm glad you
got to at least spend some moments with
your dad before he died it sounds to me
like you didn't have much of them in
your life then all of a sudden at the
end you kind of
reconciled right it seemed like yeah i
found out he got a tattoo and stuff too
it was cool man like i like
it would have been nice to have someone
around for all these moments that are
happening right now you know like the
vmas it would have been
cool to call somebody and been like yo
like
i did something call me i [ __ ] tell
you
you did good you were great at the vmas
you did a great job
your old man would be proud of you